hi I'm Erik Bosse and Avengers infinity
war is finally here and like an eager
little fanboy looking out the window for
Papa to come home boy who I have
feelings I know it's a little early and
maybe you have not seen it yet I was
lucky to see it a little early but do
not worry I'm not gonna spoil anything
this is my non-spoiler review of the
movie really just some deeper thoughts
to consider as you head into the movie
or if you have seen it a hot take to not
along - or shake away okay so how was
Avengers infinity war well answer that
question you have to consider what kind
of movie this is now it's hard to judge
infinity war as a movie because
emotionally speaking this is more of an
event than a movie a crossover finale
paying off a decade of interweaving
storylines across multiple previous
movies now a movie traditionally has
three acts introduced the hero challenge
a hero and then show what the hero does
to overcome those challenges this is
pretty much the formula that we've seen
Marvel Studios do in every one of its
past adventures taking characters and
storylines from comic books and fitting
them into a cinematic format a
redemption tale team-up caper spy
thriller buddy comedy political drama
and breakup story kind of but Infinity
Ward doesn't do that instead it plays
like a true comic book crossover issue
designed to pay off essential back
issues with interesting conflict and
teamwork and surprising pairings
spectacle after spectacle and powerful
emotional gut punches and that thrill is
infinity wars first major strength it is
all third act it's the finale to the
movie that we've been watching for ten
years now it doesn't answer all the
questions there's still another Avengers
4 in the pipeline for that but to use
Game of Thrones season 6 terms it's
definitely a penultimate battle of the
Basterds to a surely forthcoming winds
of winter the closest thing to a
protagonist we get in this movie is
Thanos himself who's the second big
strength Thanos his goal of collecting
the six Infinity stones and wiping out
half the universe is the mission that we
are most curious to see accomplished
even if it breaks our hearts to see that
happen that's how you know you have a
great villain by the way like kill
monger and black panther a part of us
kind of wants to see the evil plan
succeed mostly because we care so much
about all these characters that we want
to see how they respond and that
emotional connection is the third big
strength of infinity war the chemistry
between the characters I pointed out in
my past analyses on this channel that
the secret magic of the superhero
team-up movies is the specific visual of
Hiro's personality and abilities
complementing each other in interesting
ways Thor hammer and cap shield to
create a shockwave ant-man riding Hawk
eyes arrow Groot using his body as a
tree shield to protect the other
guardians the father-son connection
between Tony Stark and Peter Parker as
they stitch and shove together a cleaved
fairy as this whole franchise has
evolved it's less about these
personalities as individual heroes as it
is about the way they set each other up
for spikes and match each other's
strengths this cooperative ensemble
energy is the beating heart of infinity
war it leads to some of the biggest
laughs and yes some of the biggest gasps
both had scene than alley-oop each other
and that the humanity that connects all
of them I truly loved this experience I
was surprised at how a cathartic
infinity war end up being connected me
to all these little moments of joy that
I've experienced over the past 10 years
that said I don't expect everyone who
sees it to feel that way
Avengers infinity war was a gamble by
Marvel Studios it's essentially a
Hollywood version of the ploys that
Marvel comics would use creating these
big crossover events like Marvel Comics
civil war that would invest you in lots
of other character storylines that you
might not otherwise have cared that much
about like you could argue that in the
mid-2000s not a ton of people were
clamoring for a Captain America movie
until the Civil War event in the comics
now he's one of the most beloved
superheroes of Hollywood I would say
that Marvel's gamble appears to have
paid off big time in this movie ever
since Sam Jackson teased this wider
cinematic universe and the post-credits
scene of the first Iron Man most of us
really have bought into watching all
these movies so that we're all pretty
much in on the joke by now but for
anyone who isn't who maybe caught Iron
Man or The Avengers or black panther but
missed all the other movies in between
infinity war might not have the same
emotional effect kind of like a non Game
of Thrones watcher dropping in on battle
of the bastards the pacing of the
visuals and arrows it's all exciting but
you know you're not gonna feel what the
creator's want you to feel namely
satisfaction when a dog bites really
pain in the face so as a standalone
story removed from its own cinematic
history
eventine award doesn't really hold up as
its own arc you could say it's over long
and overcrowded with characters and
spectacle it doesn't
necessarily have the elegance and the
confinement of the genre Bucky and
superhero movies like Logan or the Dark
Knight but it's also not trying to do
what those movies did the Marvel
Cinematic Universe is frenzied and funny
and firework II joyful and Avengers
infinity war is the ultimate summation
of all that contained in one powerful
climax phrasing yeah I know what I said
but I'll throw it over to you guys
if you have seen the movie how do you
think it ranks up against the other MCU
films also if you have seen it just be
cool and don't spoil stuff in the
comments we don't have to block anybody
comment down below with your thoughts or
tweet me directly I da boss and
following the rockstars on Twitter for
updates on our videos like it share this
video subscribe to new rock stars for
all of our deep dives into infinity war
it is infinity week so check out our
breakdowns of some of the scenes that
have been released in advance and be on
the lookout for our panel review in this
week's new rockstars news as well as a
breakdown of the post credits scene and
all the movies Easter eggs and next
week's full movie breakdown thanks for
watching bye
[Music]